hey leute hier ist wieder einmal wandel
und das ist mein erstes kommentare
kommentiert video losgeht
kelly 2.0 kommentar kommentare
gott ist die anstrengung ins klo ich
kümmere mich nur um ja also wenn du mich
anstrengt findest dann weiß ich ja auch
nicht mehr sich dagegen tun soll und
warum musstest du die kamera war hier
das video ist ein video was ich will
wir haben damals sogar pokémon karten
getauscht hh ihr habt pokémon ihr hat
sie getauscht gucken mehr jungs oder
mädchen deine videos manchmal wirklich
so 65% jungs und alt 35 prozent mädchen
aber dann ist es mit noch in die andere
richtung also im durchschnitt glaube ich
wirklich so hay group sind toll
cooles video aber was hast du da am
rechten arm
was soll ich denn da haben eine hand
voll kkh zwischen braucht man auf der
schule ein iphone dürfte ich euch kurz
um eine schweigeminute beten
google doodle erinnert sich kein mensch
in schaan der perverser kleiner junge
ist natürlich erinnere ich mich an
schönen schaden lustiger fakt dazu sagt
mir das damals erst mal geschaut haben
heißt meine mutter innerhalb der familie
also im engsten kreis heißt sie einfach
ob sie also für die die es nicht wissen
schon hat seine mutter für immer maxi
genannt näher und unsere mutti heißt
auch maxi ohne scheiß ich hab so viel in
meiner kindheit verpasst nur weil ich
nur kika schauen durfte kein regen kein
pokémon nichts
vielleicht erzählt so dass man natascha
kampusch wird bestimmt auch in ihrer
kindheit verpasst
in klammern 11 google nur noch prosieben
sind so vorm pc oder vor der ps3 aber
die meiste zeit bin ich draußen locken
worden
ganz ehrlich passt mal bitte besser auf
deine fans auf die landen schon
mittlerweile bei mir auf den videos ich
muss jetzt einfach mal sagen dass du
echt sympathisch rüberkommt und man mit
dir bestimmt auch ab und zu scheiße
bauen kann also nicht wortwörtlich
natürlich wie zur hölle willst du
wortwörtlich scheiße bauen du hast eine
total weise ich mag dich mainz jetzt
eine meise oder nicht und ich mag diese
total lockere art in den videos danke
für dieses kompliment das finde ich sehr
nett von dir alles gut so noch mal nicht
locker genug was okay danke für dieses
kompliment das finde ich echt nett von
dir ist schon so viel dass man bei die
erster kommentare schreibt mama mama die
leute schreiben bei mir erstmal
kommentare ich bin so viel
ja ja beruhigt ich aber beruhigt ich
habe dir doch gesagt dass es klappt ja
ich lebe jetzt auf
doch nicht ich kann nur deutsch und
englisch eben und ein bisschen
französisch aber nichts besonderes
ladies und gentlemen
heute nur für sie die einzige die
unglaubliche mal war ja ja danke danke
danke danke kugel holen alle möglichen
exotischen ländern asiens eventuell
lateinamerikas ging mir durch den kopf
aber polen gut es kann sein dass ich
euch etwas verschwiegen haben aber nicht
weil ich euch nicht mag daran liegt gar
nicht dass ich habe mich nur ich weiß
nicht ich weiß einfach nicht warum ich
bin nicht nur deutsch polnisch sondern
auch italienisch kann man zwar keine
wort peter je nicht aber in meine gene
steckt das dringend und deshalb sehe ich
so aus wie ich aussehe
spaghetti das war italienisch und heißt
meine urgroßmutter kam aus italien
es ist so langweilig nur deutsch zu sein
ammann ist das langweilig auch mein gott
es ist so cool ein migrantenkind zu sein
schon damals musste ich die briefe
meiner mutter korrigieren weil sie nicht
richtig deutsch konnte zweimal hitler im
video gibt einen daumen nach oben wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal
tschüss